ask you about the last season of Game of
Thrones go ahead can you not answer
anything are you allowed to answer
anything about this event somewhat the
question is do you know how it ends yes
how did you find out how tense you got
the whole screen I read the script yeah
and how did you one word and how you
felt when you read the last episode of
Game of Thrones Wow
mixture of feelings no in one word I
don't know it was I was excited and I I
you know I I thought that you know Dan
Weiss David Benioff the creators they
they they just couldn't have done a
better job on on ending our story do you
think fans will be satisfied um I was
satisfied I don't know I mean I think
it's one of those things there'll be a
lot of you know who knows it's always
that thing you don't want it to end if
you've ever if I'm watching a show that
I love I just don't want it to end so
any ending is kind of like ah could we
just what about but no I think they will
be satisfy no we everyone on the show
have we've worked harder than ever
before like we spend twice as much time
shooting this these six episodes than we
did on two full seasons before no
expense has been spared I mean we've
we've gone all in so we really hope that
people will like it we've done our best
have you already filmed your final scene
I've filmed my final scene yes was it
emotional for you it was it yes yes it
was yeah so it's gone from your life now
it's done yeah I don't think it'll ever
be gone from you know I'm going back to
Belfast next week so it's not I'm not
100% done but the last scene in the
script I've shot that yeah how is the
last scene with me the last even - yes
shot was there anything that happened
your character that you're like this
can't happen were there two seasons were
there times where you're the seasons
yeah were there times where you thought
I can't do this or I don't want this to
happen to him or like are they going
down the right path this is a point of
no one I mean I think there was you know
shocking moments and I think that that
that's what the show has been very good
at it it's such a fine balance where
it's it's the shock to big I said take
him I think that
for me and when I read the if there's
two moments that that's the standout did
the Shireen being burned at the stake I
thought it was just cruel I mean it made
sense story wise and I understand why
they did it but I just I just couldn't
watch an idea just it was difficult to
even read it and then I thought it was
very disturbing when what's this the
name of the kid who had to who was still
being breast breastfed when he was seven
it was so weird and wrong on every level
but no other than that I think that I
mean I think the beauty of it it's it's
it's May it made sense I mean even the
most extreme things that they've been
driven by story I think at this point in
the show at the episode of the the final
season here we're really you know you
you're reaping the rewards of that the
work that's been put into all these
characters so now as an audience member
you're kind of invested in every single
one of these people which is yeah I
shouldn't talk about the ending here so
so but it's it's it it's it makes it
very interesting storytelling I think
how this game of ferns change your life
I don't know if it's changed he's a
difficult thing I think that you spent
nine years with someone you you're gonna
be like nine years ago you you were a
different person so it's difficult to
say that well I'm different now because
I've worked with a variety or because
well you've met other people in your
life a lot of things happen what is
unique about this you know as an actor
you you have to learn very early on my I
had to learn in my career that you get
so close to someone and it's so intense
and then two months later you have to
say goodbye and you might not see these
people again or you might work again ten
years from now so you have to learn how
to let go and not get too attached at
the same time you have to open up but
hear it it's been nine years since we
shot the pilot so so you've you have
gotten to know someone very very well
and you've you you I really like these
people
we've you know one of the one of the
guys said it the best we've had this
amazing I don't know if this is allowed
to say but I can
there's been no [ __ ] on the show and
we've had a big cast and a lot of a huge
crew and we haven't had any [ __ ]
it's quite something so to answer your
question has it changed me who knows we
change all the time but I'm gonna miss
all those people that's for sure hey
everybody it's Charlie so Nikolaj
coster-waldau was a can recently doing a
whole bunch of interviews for other
projects of course people were asking
him about season 8 so let's break it
down if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos there's a new round of the
giveaway for that 4k release they're
releasing Game of Thrones seasons in 4k
blu-rays now but it's gonna take him a
while to get through all the seasons so
I'll remind everybody about that at the
end of the video all you have to do to
enter those would just be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video so his
comments about the ending were similar
to what he said before I did another
video where he was doing separate
interviews I'll link that at the end of
this because he said some similar things
saying Dan and Dave did their own
version of the ending that was most true
to what the series has done will very
likely be different from George RR
Martin's dream of spring ending for Song
of Ice and Fire when he finishes writing
that and if you haven't read any of
George RR Martin's comments on that
subject people have been asking him now
that the show is ending will you change
your book story based on what the TV
show has done and he said Oh most
definitely there will be things that I
will do that they'll never be able to do
on the TV show that was even before
season 7 came out and he was mostly
hyping up the return of Lady Stoneheart
but there's just many many more
characters with very different arcs that
we'll have to resolve so obviously his
ending is gonna have to be very
different even from a practical
standpoint even if he didn't want to
stick it to Dan and Dave by doing
something really cool that you would
never be able to film the other cool
thing that Nikolaj says is that he's
filmed his final scene in the script
like the very last Jamie scene where he
probably winds up dying in the arms of
someone he loves but he's probably
already headed back to set to film more
scenes so if you haven't been following
any of the behind the scenes they're
just doing big action scenes at King's
Landing right now so they have finished
filming a lot of the
character's final moments but there's
just a lot of big practical CG work
that's left to be done so if you're
gonna have a dragon flying around King's
Landing there's just a lot of other
stuff besides actors on set having
intimate moments that you need to do for
that so that's what they're going back
for later even though those scenes won't
be the final scenes of the actual
episodes when he talks about them
reaping rewards on a story in a
character level is them paying off these
series long arcs and big twists
answering the biggest questions like how
will they defeat the knight King which
characters are gonna die will Jon Snow
and Daenerys have a child will there be
more dragons then the reunions paying
off big separations like Aria and Gendry
coming back together
Jaime sync bran for the first time since
he pushed him out the window in the
pilot that I love him talking about his
favorite WTF scenes obviously the
burning of Shireen during season 5
episode 9 was really heart-wrenching
because you loved that character you
loved the actress they had spent so much
time developing her character with sir
Davos and they paid it off so well but
Davos and Melisandre and later seasons
but then also the funny thing is is that
his other big WTF moment is the
breastfeeding of sweet Robyn way at the
beginning of season 1 that was when
Catelyn went to the Eyrie to get Lices
help with Tyrion this sort of
precipitated the events that led to the
war of the five kings so if you guys
didn't hear other related news is that
Game of Thrones confirmed that they're
not going to be doing a comic-con panel
this summer because they're still
filming technical stuff right now
they're probably going to wait to drop
some footage till they have something
that's a little more polished like
they'll be working on CG for most of the
rest of the summer while they finish
some of the practical effects but what
I'm expecting is is because in previous
seasons when we would get 10 episodes
per season and they would premiere in
April is that they would usually start
dropping footage around November so
that's when I'm expecting the first
actual footage to start dropping but
right now they're shooting the Watchmen
HBO series I think that they're gonna
try and finish that so they can premiere
that right after the game of Thrones
finale and will like just transition
into that show but like we've talked
about before they're not gonna premiere
the Game of Thrones prequel series till
the year after the finale airs so it's
going to be 2020 when the prequel series
drops probably sometime April May but
it'll be 10 episodes the one that we
heard about recently I've already done a
video about is the long night during the
Age of Heroes it's sort of like a night
king origin story but they'll be filming
that soon so we'll get a better idea for
what's going on with the characters look
like so I'll do videos for the prequel
as we get more stuff then there's the
Targaryen prequel story fire and blood
is going to be dropping later this year
in November leave all your video
requests in the comments below
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner just ice please private message
me so I can get your contact details
click here for that other Jaime
Lannister video and click here to learn
more about what's going on with the
prequel TV series thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight